[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je connais des petits enfants
qui vont être très très content ce soir
nounours leur a apporté une surprise
extraordinaire ce qu'ils vont être
contents pas trop il ne faut pas leur
dire ce que saint michel
[Musique]
nono ne regardait pas encore c'est une
surprise
cachez-vous les yeux et attendait que
j'ai compté jusqu'à 3 1 2
[Musique]
c'est un crapaud non c'est une graine
nuit une grenouille et les vrais et
mouche en salant mons
tu as des idées folles meynard honorera
fils un aveu de tout petit pas du tout
alors vous êtes contents les pays
émergents mais qu'est ce qu'elle va
manger un peu de farine note pour
grenoux qu'est ce qu'elle va boire d'un
an dans son doigt telle que tu es bête
mais elle est seulement venu vous dire
bonjour
après elle retournera dans sa maison pas
tout de suite non dans quelques villes
où elle est sa maison au fond d'une
geôle image à la campagne où elle vit
avec sa maman et ses amis grenouille
petite grenouille qui fera pas tant
carreau c'est une icône à comment elle
s'appelle cette grenouille est
je ne sais pas il faut lui trouver un
bon apprenait alors on a trouvé un os en
la caisse comme notre tente ça lui
ferait tellement plaisir faire son don à
l'éditeur joli non résidents elle parle
pas justin non mais lol quora sait
comment ça elle fait croit aux as où
croît roque rocroi ce que tu parles bien
grenouille battu pas mieux qu elle a
encore rien dit parce qu'est la semaine
allons on lui dit bonne nuit et on va se
coucher
o o
j'explique coin coin
le voilà bonne ni les ans en la jette un
oeil leur fait deux tours
cette mort est venue alors nounours
comment se porte cette petite grenouille
justin va très bien patron elle dort eh
bien nous allons faire comme elle ni les
enfants pour menu justin à demain
[Musique]